hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down the very latest
in black clover including some
absolutely
stunning and world-changing information
about
knocked and his magic along with some
major new info about the dark triads
plans
and the true nature of the tree of
cliffhoth
spoiler alert the tree of cliffhoth plan
is so much worse
and so much more dangerous than we
realized there is
a lot to talk about the rest of this
epic spade kingdom saga has just been
foreshadowed in a big way
so let's get into it if you enjoy the
black lover content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going please leave a like to let me
know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to the
channel or maybe you just haven't
subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications big shout out to my
editor dakota broski who is a major
black clover fan
and a massive noel simp definitely show
him some love by checking out his
anime youtube channel link in the
description
finally this video will of course
contain black clover manga spoilers
we are talking about the very latest
events in the story so please proceed
with caution you have been warned
we pick up where we left off last time
at the magic night captain and vice
captain meeting
inside the clover kingdom capital the
other magic knight captains do not
recognize
knocked and they assume that he is an
intruder by the way i've been getting
roasted by my german fans down in the
comments for my pronunciation of knocked
so i have to step
it up anyway the magic knight captains
feel threatened by this intruder and
they even prepare to attack him
but before they can do anything four
different shadow monsters
appear one behind nozelle one behind
jack one behind fugoleon
and one behind charlotte these strange
creatures have the faces of various
animals
and their bodies appear to be made out
of darkness or shadows
asta is shocked to see this and soar the
captains
in fact osta seems to suggest that these
four shadow monsters are four separate
devils implying that nacht might not be
possessed by a single demon or devil
but by multiple maybe even as many as
five
if we count the little one on his
shoulder as a separate demon
now i am not jumping to conclusions on
this
just yet i think there might be a
translation
issue or osta might just have the
impression that these are all
separate devils we have to remember that
nacht uses
shadow magic so these creatures could be
creations
of the shadow magic itself i don't know
it just seems crazy to me that one
person could be possessed by
five separate demons it just doesn't add
up from what we've seen so far
but if it were true it would be an
absolute game changer
a person who is possessed by one devil
is overpowered enough but a human who is
possessed
by five would be absolutely broken
as everyone is still confused about
nacht and his magic
noct smiles and says that he has a right
to be here
and julius confirms this pointing out
that this is the vice captain
of the black bulls julius says that he
didn't realize that nacht was possessed
by a devil
but he was aware of him and he knew that
he had infiltrated the spade kingdom
as a spy the very fact that julius the
guy who is the most curious
about magic in the entire kingdom did
not know the true nature of nacht's
magic
is in itself insane and as jack thinks
about it he realized that he has seen
nacht
once before it seems that yami and nacht
have actually known each other for a
long time
and it looks like they were both members
of the azure deer squad
at the same time back before yami became
the black bull's captain
even though everyone in the room is
still stunned and confused about
knocked knocked doesn't waste any time
he quickly goes on to explain the dark
and terrifying truth about the dark
triad and the fate
of william and yami as we all know
the dark triad is planning to use the
tree of clifforth to open a
portal between this world and the demon
world a portal which will be located
inside the spade kingdom and which will
allow countless demons to freely enter
this world if the plan succeeds the
result
will be mass destruction and the
annihilation of
90 percent of the world's population
what's more in order to open the tree of
cliffhoth
the dark triad will need to sacrifice
yami and william
once the ritual begins there are only 7
days
before it is completed at which point
both yami
and william will be killed seven gates
must be opened in order for the two
worlds to connect and presumably one
gate must be opened
every day over the course of 7 days but
if that
wasn't enough at the location where this
ritual is set to take place
there are apparently 10 different devils
who are coordinating the tree of
clifford
ritual the weakest demons are at the top
and the strongest ones are
at the bottom from the illustration that
we see there appear to be nine levels
to the tree of cliffhoth which is
identical to the nine circles of hell
in dante's inferno there are two demons
on the top level
and then one each on the other eight
levels
the ones at the top are about as strong
as the members of the dark triad
and the one at the very bottom is
lucifer or lucifero
himself lucifer is of course dante's
demon
and this implies that dante's demon is
in fact the strongest out of all of them
in dante's inferno not the dante from
black clover but the dante who was an
italian writer but you get the reference
lucifer himself is trapped in the center
of the ninth circle of hell
which by the way is a frozen wasteland
so it seems to me that the tree of
cliffhoth
is in fact a direct reference to dante's
inferno
nacht says that the bad news is that
yami and william will be killed as part
of this ritual
but the good news is that they won't be
killed until the very end of the ritual
so there is still some time to rescue
them real wonders
why the dark triad would want to do
something as horrible and dangerous as
connecting this world and the demon
world
but noct explains that the triad doesn't
care about
reason or logic they are psychos who
like to cause pain
for its own sake and they feel no sense
of guilt whatsoever for making
other people suffer so essentially they
are psychotic agents of chaos without a
conscience
and nacht says that he hates people like
that most of all
then in a rare moment of seriousness for
an otherwise always cheerful and smiling
knocked
the black bull vice captain says that
even if god
or the devil forgives the dark triad he
will not forgive them this seems to
suggest
that this whole situation is somehow
personal for knocked
and that he might have a deeply
emotional reason for wanting to destroy
the dark triad it could just be the noct
is actually really close friends with
yami and he is angry at them for
capturing him
even though he claims to hate yami
publicly or there might be something
else going on here that we still don't
know about
after all noct's entire backstory is a
complete mystery to us
so who knows what dark secrets the vice
captain
is still hiding but as strong and
determined as nacht clearly is
he realizes that he simply cannot defeat
the dark triad and all those demons
on his own so he has decided to make
asta
as strong as possible because anti-magic
is the key to defeating the dark triad
once and for all knocked then
explains what their mission is and man
what a crazy
and dangerous mission they only have a
few days to rescue yami and william
before the tree of cliffhoth is opened
and the entire world
is destroyed in order to prevent the
ritual from being completed
they must create an elite tactical force
that will be able to infiltrate the
spade kingdom while protecting asta
and allowing him to make the best
possible use of his anti-magic
the magic knight captains and vice
captains asta
julius and all the most powerful mages
in the kingdom
must prepare themselves because now is
the time to attack
they must go on the attack before it's
too late they must
stop the ritual save yami and william
and destroy the trio cliffhoth
failure to complete this mission will
not only result in the deaths of yami
and william
but also in the deaths of like 90
percent of the world's population
wow what an intense and insane mission
the stakes have literally never been
higher and the pressure
is really on this chapter serves as the
perfect setup for the next stage
of this epic spade kingdom saga and i
expect that things are going to keep
heating up from here
so far we had the dark triad to worry
about and the three demons who are
possessing them
but we just learned that there are
apparently at least
10 demons guarding the tree of cliff off
and the clock
is ticking in only a few days it will
all be over so they have to act
right now if you were expecting a long
training arc that would allow asta to
get much stronger before rescuing yami
you may need to readjust your
expectations very quickly
i mean unless the clover kingdom has
some sort of equivalent to the
hyperbolic time chamber from dragon ball
asta simply will not have enough time to
train
and neither will anyone else man first
of all
we need more information about noct's
shadow magic
what were those monsters and are they
really the equivalent of multiple
separate devils or are they something
else like
creations of nocht's shadow magic maybe
nacht has a single devil who can just
split himself
into multiple creatures since we already
know that he has multiple forms he
already confirmed this
i don't know what do you guys think is
it possible that knocked might be
possessed by
multiple demons slash devils or is
something else going on here
also how crazy is this mission to rescue
yami and william
going to be they need an elite task
force of the very strongest mages
so i'm thinking mario leona fugolion
charlotte
dorothy knocked osta literally everyone
the best of the best
and they must all join forces for one
epic assault
on the spade kingdom i absolutely can't
wait
to see this definitely let me know who
you think will join
this elite force down in the comments
below if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
black lover content right here on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know
it really does help and if you happen to
be new to anime out pro
or maybe you just haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a lot of our videos even
if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
a very special thank you to alpha sigma
a disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata alolan
adam the world
acquired respect pate heffa jonathan
king
brandon aviles papa smurf emperor otaku
thomas jones kid mono
and admirath finally thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson king
zeldris anatoly kazotsky
angel cruz cricket xp joe stanton very
gucci
alicia octor jessica califond hinokai
and water bonnie parks ratheora florian
joni garcia steelers deadly saint and
stern hawkins
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you